NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF ALLERGY
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND A
PUBLIC SERVANT FOR DECADES.
DR. FAUCI, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
UM, THE SENATOR PAUL APART FROM
MANY OTHERS WHO ATTACKED YOU IS
HE TWAUL TWALLY GRADUATED FROM
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
HE IS A MEDICAL DOCTOR, WHICH I
FIND REMARKABLE.
HOW DO YOU SQUARE THAT WITH WHAT
IS COMING OUT OF HIS MOUTH?
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU SAID WHAT
WE ARE ALL HERE FOR TODAY,
TALKING ABOUT THE PANEL IN FRONT
OF YOU, CLEARLY WHAT HE IS THERE
FOR AND MANY OF THOSE ARE THERE
FOR, AS AT MANY PUBLIC HEARINGS,
IS TO MAKE SOUND BYTES THAT --
THAT GET ATTENTION AND, AGAIN,
SPUR DONATIONS ON HIS WEBSITE.
>> THAT IS TRUE, ANDERSON, AND
IT REALLY IS UNFORTUNATE.
I MEAN, PUTTING ME ASIDE WITH
ALL THE AD HOMINEMS AND THINGS
THAT YOU SHOWED ON THAT FILM,
THE HEARING WAS A VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
GOOD FAITH EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS
DISAGREEMENT -- POLITICAL AND
OTHER DISAGREEMENT ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE.
I MEAN, SENATOR MURRAY AND
SENATOR BURR REALLY WANTED TO
GET DOWN TO THE BOTTOM OF SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE ON.
SO, IN -- AND EVEN THE
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WERE -- WERE
ASKING GOOD, TOUGH QUESTIONS.
AND -- AND WE SHOULD BE HAVING
TO RESPOND TO TOUGH QUESTIONS.
UM, AND YET, THE ONLY THING THAT
CAME OUT OF SENATOR RAND PAUL
AND, TO SOME EXTENT, SENATOR
ROGER MARSHAL, WERE AD HOMINEM
WHICH DOES NOTHING BUT DISTRACT
FROM WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
DOING.
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC THAT EVERYONE
KNOWS LIKE NOW IS LIKE A TSUNAMI
ON US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE CLOSE TO A
MILLION PEOPLE A DAY GETTING
INFECTED.
AND WE HAVE CLOSE TO A MILLION
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO DIE --
850,000 PEOPLE DYING.
AND INSTEAD OF USING IT IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER, THEY'RE
DISTRACTING IT WITH THINGS THAT
ARE PATENTLY UNTRUE.
SO, I -- I CAN'T EXPLAIN THAT,
ANDERSON, EXCEPT WHAT I BROUGHT
UP AT THE HEARING -- THAT IT
CLEARLY IS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
THERE -- THERE -- HE IS -- HE'S
RAISING MONEY FOR HIS CAMPAIGN
BY MAKING ME THE VILLAIN.
HE CALLS ME A POLARIZING FIGURE.
WELL, IF YOU CALL ME A MURDERER
AND SAY I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
RIDICULOUS, PREPOSTEROUS,
SLANDEROUS STATEMENTS,
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATHS OF 5
MILLION PEOPLE DOING THIS AND
DOING THAT, IT'S NOT ME THAT'S
MAKING MYSELF POLARIZING.
IT'S HIM.
THE ONLY THING I AM TRYING TO DO
IS WHAT YOU LOOK ON THE RECORD
OF EVERYTHING I'VE EVER SAID.
GETTING PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED, TO GET BOOSTED, TO
WEAR MASKS, TO ABIDE BY THE CDC
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE POLARIZING,
ANDERSON.
THAT'S JUST PUBLIC HEALTH.
HE'S MAKING ME POLARIZED BY
SAYING THINGS ABOUT ME THAT ARE
COMPLETELY UNTRUE.
>> THERE -- YOU KNOW, IN
COURTROOMS, LAWYERS AREN'T
SUPPOSED TO ASK A QUESTION OF A
DEFENDANT THAT THEY DON'T
ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
THAT'S A LESSON THAT ONE
SENATOR, CLEARLY, HAS NOT
LEARNED.
SENATOR ROGER MARSHAL SAID
SOMETHING TO YOU TODAY, AND I
JUST -- I JUST WANT TO PLAY THIS
BECAUSE AGAIN IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS I FOUND KIND OF
STUNNING.
>> AS THE HIGHEST-PAID EMPLOYEE
IN THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, YES OR NO, WOULD YOU
BE WILLING TO SUBMIT TO CONGRESS
AND THE PUBLIC A FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE THAT INCLUDES YOUR
PAST AND CURRENT INVESTMENTS?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
ARE ASKING ME THAT QUESTION.
MY FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE IS
PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE, AND HAS BEEN
SO FOR THE LAST 37 YEARS OR SO.
35 YEARS.
>> WHERE WOULD WE FIND IT?
>> ALL YOU WOULD HAVE TO DO IS
ASK FOR IT.
I -- I -- YOU'RE SO MISINFORMED,
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
>> WELL, WHY --
>> SENATOR MARSHAL, DR. FAUCI
HAS ANSWERED YOU.
IT IS PUBLIC INFORMATION, AND HE
IS HAPPY TO GET IT TO YOU IF YOU
WOULD ASK.
SENATOR MORAN.
>> WHAT A MORON.
>> UM, SO LET ME JUST TELL YOU
JUST AS A TELEVISION -- AS
SOMEONE WHO EXISTS ON
TELEVISION, I CAN TELL YOU
SOMEONE WROTE THAT QUESTION FOR
HIM.
THE WAY I KNOW THIS IS BECAUSE
HE IS LOOKING DOWN AT HIS PIECE
OF PAPER, JUST READING THIS
QUESTION THAT HAS, CLEARLY, BEEN
WRITTEN FOR HIM.
SOMEONE HAS MADE, UNFORTUNATELY,
A LARGE, GIANT CHECK AND HE
THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO BE
THIS BIG KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
EXTRAORDINARY REVEAL.
THAT'S WHAT WHOEVER PREPARED
THAT QUESTION FOR HIM HAD TOLD
HIM.
AND THEN, WHEN YOU ANSWERED IT,
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
BECAUSE THAT -- THERE WAS NO
FOLLOWUP FOR HIM AND HE WAS
UNAWARE THAT THAT'S PUBLIC
INFORMATION.
AND THEN, HE JUST -- IT JUST
WENT DOWNHILL FROM THERE.
UM, THAT WASN'T EVEN ABOUT
SCIENCE.
I MEAN, HOW DIFFICULT IS IT TO
ADDRESS THE ACTUAL PANDEMIC WHEN
IT'S THESE KIND OF QUESTIONS
BEING ASKED AT A HEARING,
OBVIOUSLY, WITH GREAT SETUP AND
THIS IS WHAT HIS STAFF HAS BEEN
PREPARING HIM TO ASK?
>> WELL, THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT,
ANDERSON, WHICH I SAID.
IT WAS SO COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
WHAT THE INTENT OF THE HEARING
IS.
THE HEARING IS WE ARE DEALING
WITH A CATASTROPHIC PANDEMIC
THAT HAS ALREADY KILLED OVER
850,000 AMERICANS.
AND THERE WAS GOOD FAITH ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, AND MANY OF
THE REPUBLICANS AND -- AND THE
DEMOCRATS, OF COURSE, AND IT WAS
LED BY, YOU KNOW, IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY BY SENATOR BURR
AND SENATOR MURRAY.
AND YET, THE ONLY THING HE HAD
IN MIND WAS AD HOMINEM WHEN I
THINK THAT IS THE REAL ISSUE